thing is we want to graph the point so
we've got negative five negative twelve
so you're gonna go left five on the
x-axis and twelve down on the y-axis so
left five down twelve okay just like you
would normally plot a point and then
what you're going to do is you're going
to draw a ray to that point from the
origin so you can see this is making a
right triangle then what you can do is
you can do the Pythagorean theorem or if
you know your Pythagorean triples you
can find this missing side here and in
this case it's 13 now the hypotenuse
here this radius or this ray drawn from
the origin is always going to be
positive okay so again if you're not
sure just go ahead and do the
Pythagorean theorem negative 5 squared
plus negative 12 squared equals C
squared and you're gonna see that this
is 25 plus 144 equals C squared 169
equals C squared take the square root of
both sides and you can see that C is
coming out 213 okay so now that we've
got our triangle what we do is we
position ourself here at the origin to
find our ratios so if we want to find
the sine of theta I'll just put it here
sine of theta what we do is we look at
our sohcahtoa acronym to help us so we
say sine is the opposite over hypotenuse
cosine is the adjacent side over the
hypotenuse and tangent is the opposite
side over the adjacent side so what
we're gonna do here sine of theta is
going to be the opposite which is
negative 12 over the hypotenuse which is
across from the right angle
that's 13 and you've got it now if you
want to find the reciprocal ones like
the cosecant of theta all you have to do
is take the reciprocal and this is going
to be 13 over negative 12 okay let's go
to the cosine now so the cosine of theta
is adjacent over hypotenuse so adjacent
is next 2 over the hypotenuse so this is
negative 5 over 13 and if you want to
find the secant of theta you just take
the reciprocal that's 13 over negative 5
okay let's go to the tangent now so the
tangent of theta is opposite over
adjacent so that's negative 12 over
negative 5 you can see the two natives
cancel so that's 12th ists and then the
cotangent of theta we just take the
reciprocal of the tan
and that's 5:12 and you got